Welcome to Hot Topics
in Computing at MIT.
I'm Dan Huttenlocher, the
dean of the Schwarzman
College of Computing.
We're really delighted to
have Brad Smith, the president
and also the chief legal
officer at Microsoft.
While many of us see technology
as a double edged sword,
as technologists we often
tend to see the opportunity
and the potential for
good in new technologies,
maybe blinding us to the
other edge of the sword.
Brad really stands
out in his ability
to articulate the balance of
positive and negative impacts
from technologies and how
to get better outcomes
overall from understanding and
addressing these in advance.
He's really transformed
how Microsoft
and much of the tech industry
see computing technology.
Growing out of the
Department of Justice actions
against Microsoft
in the 1990s, he
began framing the challenges
as well as the opportunities
of new technologies in ways
that technology leaders could
appreciate.
He successfully
brought Bill Gates,
one of the great technology
leaders of the 20th century,
on this journey, and
I would say instilling
in him and the company
the important roles
of many societal and
government actors
as we think about technology.
I think that we have a
lot to learn from Brad.
While I know that
we're going to learn
a lot in today's
fireside chat, I also
really highly recommend his
recent book, Tools and Weapons.
It has compelling,
even, I would say,
page turning vignettes,
each of which
makes deeper and important
points about technology
and its positive and
negative impacts.
We have about 250
questions that participants
submitted in advance.
We'll be getting to some of the
more frequent ones of those.
And you can also enter questions
at the bottom of your screen.
Brad is going to be
joined by Daniela
Rus in this fireside chat.
She's the deputy
dean of academics
here in the Schwarzman College
and the director of CSAIL.
I'm sure we're in for
a great conversation.
Daniela and Brad.
Thank you, Dan.
We are so excited to
welcome Brad Smith
to our virtual campus today.
Our teams first discussed
this event in the winter.
And this feels so
long ago by now.
Because Brad, there's
been so much happening
in these past few
months that has
had a big imprint on
technology, so I'm really
eager to get into
this conversation.
We have many MIT
students with us today.
And they submitted
over 200 questions.
So let's get started.
Now first, I saw that
your CEO, Satya Nadella,
said that Microsoft
has seen two years
worth of digital
transformation in two months.
And all sorts of
organizations are working
on COVID-related research.
I'd like to start
by asking you, what
do you view as the
biggest challenges
Microsoft has faced so far and
what lessons have you learned?
Well, first, thank you, Daniela.
Thank you, Dan.
And thanks to everybody
for watching this.
I do want to just open
by saying how much we
at Microsoft appreciate the
opportunity to work with all
of you at MIT and,
frankly, how much we
learn from working with of you.
It's such an important
relationship and partnership
for us.
Eric Horvitz leads
a lot of the work
here to work with you all,
including on the issues
that we'll be talking about
today around trustworthy
and ethical artificial
intelligence
and other technology.
But I do think-- look, let's
start with the obvious.
This is a time unlike
any in our lifetime.
You literally have
to go back 102 years
to find a pandemic that has had
the reach that COVID-19 has.
I think it's
interesting to think
about how different the world's
response is in the year 2020,
not just compared to 1918,
but just imagine if this
had happened in 2010 or 2005.
In so many ways the
world has gone digital.
And this event itself, I
think, really illustrates that.
You know, interestingly
for us at Microsoft,
having our own
people work from home
has not been that
difficult. Trevor Noah
joked with me-- we work
together on a number of things--
that just we were sort of
practicing for this every day
just by being Microsoft, by
developing this technology
that we use every day.
But our role throughout
this has really
been to support all of the other
organizations and institutions,
governments, nonprofits,
businesses, literally
on a global scale that
have had to transition
to so much more remote work.
And one of the
interesting things
you realize, and
I think it speaks
to sort of the multifaceted
aspects of technology
that we're talking about today,
is that of course you start
with the technology itself.
What is it that
people want to deploy?
Is it Teams?
Or is it more cloud services?
That is sort of a
natural starting point.
But then you immediately
realize that you
can't deploy that without
fundamentally changing business
processes, government processes.
We've seen the Ministry
of Justice in Italy
take all of its trials online.
We've seen so many
companies take so many
of their business
processes, customer delivery
processes online.
And so we have to work
hand-in-hand with them.
We're not a company
that can just say,
here's the tech, good luck,
let us know how it turns out.
We work with them to then
customize their solutions that
work on top of our platform.
And then there's
one final aspect
that I think has
been so interesting.
It's the old adage that
you need a clear strategy,
but ultimately, culture
eats strategy for breakfast.
I think this has
been illustrated
really interestingly
in our schools,
including our public schools
in the United States.
I think they've
struggled in many states.
They don't have the connectivity
for students at home.
They don't have the devices.
But even when they
do all of that,
you really realize you
have to work with teachers.
They need to learn not just
how to use the technology
but to create a
culture for a classroom
when the students
aren't in the room.
And so it's not just a
huge technology challenge,
it's an enormous
human challenge.
And I think the
great opportunity
for us has been the
ability to just stand next
to our customers and sort of
walk a mile in their shoes
so that we can try to
explore all of this together.
You know, that's been just
an extraordinary opportunity
for learning for us.
Are there particular
efforts you have
been most proud of with
respect to this work?
Well, I think in the short run,
this is a public health crisis.
It's a public health
crisis that has created
a profound economic crisis.
But I'd start with
public health.
I think one of the
things that has emerged
is that data has become the
indispensable tool to address
the public health
aspects of this.
Think about the
decisions that governors
are making in the United
States that they've never
impacted our life even
remotely as much as they
have in recent months.
They're running the economy.
They're deciding who
can leave their house
and who needs to stay home.
But they are decisions that
need to be based on data, data
about the spread
of the infection,
data about hospital
capacity, data
about different
counties in the state
and the mortality that is
being seen and the like.
And so we've worked very closely
with the counties and states
in the United States,
with national governments,
and with the World
Health Organization
to really transform the way
they are collecting data,
the way they're reporting it,
the way they're sharing it
with other leaders,
the way they're
sharing it with the public.
So that has been just
sort of one of the slices
I've seen in the
public health space.
I think another really
interesting example
does come from the AI
kinds of technologies
that you all at MIT have
been so involved in.
It has been sort of a
moment of real importance
for conversational AI.
We had developed an AI, a chat
bot that was being deployed
by a hospital here in Seattle.
Well, it's now being deployed
by over 1,500 institutions
in 23 countries.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
And basically, what it does
is it allows an individual who
may think they might
need a COVID-19
test to go through
a conversation that
will begin to determine
whether they in fact do.
And if so, it can hand
off the individual
to a human via
telehealth service.
But in April, that was
used 190 million times.
So just think about
that, that explosion.
And that is, I think,
a great manifestation
of two years of digitization
taking place in two months.
That's truly extraordinary.
And now let me stay with COVID
data for a minute and ask you,
so I know you've
said that you are
skeptical about the
use of contact tracing.
And I'm just wondering
what leads you
to believe this is the case.
Well, first of all,
contact tracing
is of fundamental
importance in the case
of any communicable disease.
Now I will be
quick to say, I say
this as a person who
on New Year's Eve
could have written down
perhaps everything I
knew about public health on
the back of a postage stamp.
This has been a crash
course for all of us.
But certainly what we
learn from the present
and from the past is
that for over a century
whenever anybody
has a disease that
is spread in an
infectious way, they're
interviewed by a
public health officer.
And basically part
of the routine
is, where have you
been, who did you see.
And the public health officer
then contacts, typically
by phone or email, each
of those individuals.
That is a process that is
fundamentally important.
Now we're talking about
deploying apps for that.
I think that's a good thing.
Don't get me wrong.
I think that app-based contact
tracing is an important tool.
But I think we should recognize
that it is a tool and not
a panacea.
It is, in my view, sort of a
belt and suspender approach.
We still will need
public health officers
to interview each individual who
tests positive over the phone
or in person, even
if they've been using
an app on their
smartphone that has,
say, something like
Bluetooth-based contact data
on it.
Why?
Well, the first reason
is not everybody
is going to walk around
with an app on their phone.
In Western Europe, in North
America, it's very clear,
governments are not going
to make this mandatory.
Even in Singapore,
where it's not mandatory
but they have exhorted
the population
to use this technology,
they've struggled to get it
above a 20% adoption rate.
The second thing
to just remember
is even if you
could get everybody
who has a phone to use the
app, not everybody has a phone.
Some of the most vulnerable
people in this pandemic
are homeless people.
There are people who are
elderly in nursing homes.
So we just can't base our
planning on the assumption
that everyone will
have this app.
Finally, we need
to recognize, this
is a smartphone
we're talking about.
It's not an ankle bracelet.
People forget to take it with
them to the grocery store.
The battery dies.
So I think it's
an important tool.
I think it's very valuable.
I think it can make
life easier and it
can make this whole approach to
contact tracing more effective.
But it won't replace
the humans who need
to do this contact tracing.
And frankly, it won't
replace the need
for individuals who
test positive still
to go through a
lengthy interview.
What about privacy with
respect to contact tracing?
Is that a concern?
Well, I think it absolutely is.
And I think it's an important
thing for us to focus on.
And I think it's the kind of
thing that should call on us
both narrowly and
broadly to remember,
we need to address
some new problems
but we don't need to throw what
I would call timeless values
out the window to do so.
A few weeks ago we published
seven privacy principles.
And in some ways, I
think some of them
reflect the degree to which
you can harmonize, say,
the protection of privacy
and the protection
of public health, and then
you can get to the issues
there where there may be some
real tension between them.
But for example, if we are
using this app and this data
to protect public
health, I don't
think it's a stretch to say then
the only proper use of the data
is to protect public health.
And I don't think it's
a stretch to tell people
that their data
will not be retained
beyond the point in time
in which it's actually
useful to protect public health.
Those are two principles where
I think we can actually advance
both causes at the same time.
There are other areas where
there are certain tensions,
but we believe these
can mostly be reconciled
and we think we can
do this in a way that,
by and large, strongly upholds
the protection of privacy.
And I think that
should be our goal.
So this is a great segue to
talking about your book, Tools
and Weapons, which I finished
reading over the weekend
and I enjoyed it very much.
The book read to me like
an action adventure book
with geeks as the heroes.
So thank you for that.
So to me, the book
summarizes your views
on the roles
companies should take
in having a more
moral stance on how
technology is viewed and used.
And the book also includes
some great historical context.
I loved the
backstories for events
I remember, for instance,
failing to track Daniel Pearl's
kidnappers, successfully
finding Charlie Hebdo attackers,
and hearing about how
your CEO, Satya Nadella,
decided that the
security patches
for WannaCry should be broadly
available to the public.
And so my first
question is, what
inspired you to write
this book and what did you
want to communicate
to the public with it?
Well, first of all,
thank you for reading it.
I do find that when you
do an event like this,
it encourages people to finish
it the weekend before we talk.
So thank you.
I love your description,
because I do think you're right.
In our minds, geeks are the
heroes of a lot of dramas
that involve very
important inhuman problems.
Carol Ann Browne
is my co-author.
We work together at Microsoft.
And we really wrote
the book to try
to reach a broader audience,
to bring these stories to life,
to let people see how they have
been addressed in practice,
not just at Microsoft but in
many other places as well,
to draw on some
lessons from history.
Because in our mind,
the tool of the book
really captures the
challenge we think we face.
Digital technology, I think, is
the world's most powerful tool
for so many huge problems,
but it has become
a formidable weapon as well.
And so our ultimate goal is
to broaden the conversation
that we think the world needs to
have about where technology is
going, how it needs
to be managed,
and how it needs
to actually build
on the geeks who are the heroes,
but now recognize that we're
at a point where
these issues are
of broad importance
for everybody.
You don't have to
be a student at MIT.
You don't need to have a
PhD in computer science
to have an important
role to play.
These issues affect all of us.
And if nothing
else, as consumers,
as citizens, and as voters,
we're at a point in time
where I think we all benefit
if everyone is better informed.
So let's dig a
little bit deeper.
In your book, you say
that the two inflection
points of this decade are
Cambridge Analytica and Edward
Snowden's revelations.
Can you elaborate what
makes these events so
important in your mind?
Well, if you look back at
the period from 2010 to 2020,
I do think these were
two inflection points.
The Snowden disclosures
happened in the summer of 2013.
And what they did, more
than anything else, I think,
is awaken the public, not
just in the United States,
but around the world, to the
degree to which governments
had access to so much data
about each and every one of us.
And it led to a effort to
reform government surveillance
and create more
protection for people.
One of the fascinating
moments for me
is a story we share in the book.
It was being in the
Roosevelt Room in the West
Wing of the White House at a
meeting in December of 2013
with President Obama, Vice
President Biden, the White
House senior staff, and 18
leading tech executives.
And as each of us were pushing
President Obama to reform
government surveillance, there
came this interesting moment
when he looked around
the table and he said,
I just want you
all to recognize,
you all have more
data about people
than the government does.
And he said, I have a suspicion
that the guns will turn
and there will be a moment
when the demands that you're
placing on the government
will be placed on you as well.
I thought it was a very
insightful comment at the time.
I wrote it down, and I looked
around and I was struck,
no one else was writing it down.
And that moment came.
It came-- it took
five years, which
would have been, frankly, longer
than I predicted at the time.
But it took 2018, and it
was Cambridge Analytica.
I think for a variety of
reasons that we describe
in the book, that is the moment
when then the public focused
more on the amount of data that
tech companies have on them.
And it's really a watershed
political moment, in my view,
because it started to
unleash more scrutiny of tech
companies, certainly
in the United States,
but equally important,
perhaps even more important,
on a global basis.
So data bring us back to
privacy considerations.
You have a wonderful
chapter in your book
that presents privacy
as a human right.
And you start this
chapter on privacy
by describing your experience
in Berlin when you visited
the headquarters of Stasi.
And for me, this was a very
powerful moment of the book,
since I was born in Romania
during Stasi-like times.
You also say that this was one
of the most memorable moments
of that year for you.
How is this?
How did this experience of
visiting the Stasi headquarters
impact your views on
privacy as a human right?
Well, it really was a moving
moment for me, for Carol Ann,
and for others from Microsoft
who were on this visit.
In what was East Berlin,
the former Stasi prison
is now a museum.
And we had the opportunity
to walk through the prison
with an individual who was
a prisoner there in 1968.
You know, he's a
lot like a lot of us
who are all
connected here today.
In 1968, he was 24 years old.
His name is
Hans-Jochen Scheidler.
He was pursuing a graduate
degree in physics at the time.
He was studying at the
University of Prague.
And 1968 was the year
of the Prague Spring.
Well, he was back in Berlin when
the Warsaw Pact tanks rolled
through Prague, just shut
down the liberalization
that was taking place there.
He and three of his friends
were very upset about this.
So they printed up
these little leaflets
and they handed them out
to people one evening.
He was reported to the Stasi.
They picked him up that night.
They took him to this prison,
where for many, many months,
he never saw another human being
except for the individuals who
were interrogating them.
He was never given the
opportunity to read anything.
opportunity to write.
His parents had no idea
what had happened to him.
But when you think
about what put him there
in the first place, it was
this extraordinary degree
of surveillance that
the Stasi had unleashed
on the people of East Germany,
using all of the technology
and hundreds of
thousands of informants.
And when you think about what
he did, he wrote a few lines
and he handed it out to people.
Well, in our day, that's
called sending a text message.
It's called writing an email.
And with cloud computing
and online services,
we now live in a world
where if we're not careful,
any government can use
the power of technology
to unleash
surveillance on a scale
that the Stasi could
not have imagined.
And you see what can happen when
that kind of power is abused.
And I think it's just
really important for us
to use that as inspiration.
One of the most
interesting moments for me
was to share a short
video that we produced.
We had a camera crew
with us on that visit.
And we have an annual
sales meeting at Microsoft.
It's in T-Mobile
Arena in Las Vegas.
You're speaking
to 15,000 people.
And as you can imagine
at a sales meeting,
mostly it's, this was a great
year, we're doing really well.
Everybody's so enthusiastic.
And I showed that video.
And I frankly worried.
You know, I was like, well,
this is a bit of a downer.
Is this going to land well?
But I thought it was so
important for our employees
to see that through
their own eyes.
And I will frankly
always remember
not just the visit to the
museum and the prison,
but the standing ovation
of all of our employees.
To me, I think this is the
message for everybody who's
watching now.
It is our time.
And it is, frankly, going
to be your generation that
will decide how this
technology impacts peoples'
rights around the world.
And I think we have
to learn from the past
and, frankly, just
resolve together
that we won't allow that
kind of thing to be repeated.
Brad, that's so powerful to me.
Let me follow up with
a question on where
you see the role of technology
and of the legal system
to ensure our privacy
as a human right?
Well, I think two things
need to go together.
First, just as technology
can be weaponized,
as that last example showed,
it is a powerful tool
for the protection
of human rights.
We're using it, for example,
with George and Amal Clooney.
Amal Clooney is one of the
great human rights lawyers
in the world.
And with the Clooney
Foundation for Justice,
we've created a cloud
service and an app
so that monitors to
go into courtrooms
around the world,
courtrooms where
journalists, or women, or
people from the LGBT community
are potentially being persecuted
and then prosecuted in ways
that put their rights at risk.
And you can capture data, you
can share it with the world,
you can ensure
that that trial is
evaluated by judicial
experts in other countries.
All of that is happening.
That's just one small
example of all of the ways
that technology can
be used, I think,
to promote the protection
of human rights.
But I do think at
the end of the day,
there is no substitute
for protection
under the law itself,
protection by judges and courts.
And so a lot of what
we need to focus on
is how technology and the
law can advance together
to meet these broad needs.
That's really one of
the other things that
inspired us to write this book.
Yes.
And technology and
law need to understand
each other's language
and capabilities in order
to make that path
forward together.
Now a related issue to
privacy is security.
And you are instrumental
in guiding Microsoft
toward building a strong
security foundation.
And you decided that
Microsoft needed
to be the most secure company
and held your ground on this,
which was visionary and
courageous, especially
at a time when
people did not really
care about the
privacy of their data
and other companies were
betting on advertising.
I'm just wondering
about the back story.
How did you decide on the
importance of security?
Well, I think security became
so fundamentally important
beginning in about
the year 2000.
You know, software was designed
for the personal computer,
but no one envisioned that the
personal computer would always
be connected to the world.
And so we recognized that
that was going to take place.
And we saw the attacks
that started to take place.
And so we started
to harden computers,
we started to harden network
architecture and software.
And what we really
then learned was
that we needed to keep pace.
And we needed to rely
not just on technology
to protect people,
but we were going
to need to work with
governments in new ways.
We were going to need to work
with the rest of the industry.
We were going to need
to advocate for stronger
laws around the world.
And so it was really that
combination that I think
led us to put
ourselves on a journey.
It's a journey that
continues today.
We continue to see nation
states becoming more aggressive.
And so we're having
to figure out
exactly what new
initiatives we need to take.
It's institutions at
MIT that, of course,
play an extraordinarily
important role as well.
We're all in this
together and we're all
focused on acting together.
Brad, with elections
coming up this fall,
a lot of states and counties are
talking about the possibility
of voting apps.
What's your take on the
security of electronic voting?
Well, I think the
interesting thing
is in a world where we
take for granted security
for financial transactions every
day, we're not yet in a world
where we have security for
elections and voting the way
we would like.
And so what I think
we're going to need to do
is look towards the
future, where we frankly
can have online voting.
Why not?
But it is going to take time
to be able to deploy it well.
I think one of the
things to just recognize
is we engage in
financial transactions
every moment of the day.
There's billions every day.
Voting happens infrequently.
It's a powerful reminder
that just in life we
get better at things
that we do frequently
than things that we do rarely.
But I think we need to put
ourselves on an ongoing quest
to develop more secure
online voting solutions.
In the meantime, what
we urgently need to do
is secure the voting
systems that exist today.
In so many places in
the United States,
we have voting machines
that are 10 or 15 years old.
And so one of the
really urgent needs,
including for this
election year,
is to keep working, typically
with municipalities,
with counties, with states, to
harden their voting systems.
Now you have a
powerful chapter on AI
and democracy in your book.
And you also warn about
a potential digital 9/11.
What are you doing to prevent
this, meaning what is Microsoft
doing to prevent this?
Well, first of all,
I would just say
if you think about what
a digital 9/11 would
be, I think it's two things.
One is it would be a
government attacking.
Attacking, say, so that the
electrical grid goes down,
hospitals go down.
That is what happened
in 2017 with WannaCry.
The National Health Service
in the United Kingdom, a third
of their hospitals went down.
Cash registers, ATMs,
everything stops working.
That's what happened in Ukraine
with the NotPetya attack.
But ultimately I think
one of the worst attacks
could be if we learned
a week after an election
that voting had been tampered
with, that the voting rolls had
been tampered with.
I think if something
like that were to happen,
then I think we'd
have a real issue.
I mean, just think
what it would mean
if no one had confidence to know
who had been elected president.
That would be a
fundamental problem.
Our entire basis for society,
I think, would be put at risk.
I couldn't agree with you more.
And I'm so glad that Microsoft
and many other organizations
and researchers, including
a lot of researchers at MIT,
are working on the
challenge of security.
I'd like to turn it over
to a different topic,
and that is regulation.
And I was very intrigued.
Because in your book,
you make an argument
that I think is a bit rare
among executives of major tech
companies.
And that is that Silicon
Valley needs more regulation.
And so I wonder,
can we get specific?
In what particular areas
do you think companies
like Microsoft need
more regulation?
Well, first of all, I think
we should recognize broadly
that a well functioning
market typically
has room for lots
of innovation, lots
of room for entrepreneurialship,
but a layer of regulation.
We have more confidence
in the safety of food
and drugs because of the FDA.
We have more confidence
in the safety of our cars
and aircraft because of
regulatory authorities.
So when you put
things in that lens,
I do believe that digital
technology has reached
a point where it would
benefit from more regulation,
not the kind of regulation
that would stifle creativity,
but I do think to
protect privacy,
I think to protect
security, I think
to ensure the responsible use
of artificial intelligence.
That's why we've
called for regulation
of facial recognition
technology.
We now have the first
example of that,
a state law passed
in Washington state,
I think not coincidentally,
where Microsoft is based.
So we have all of
that to learn from.
I think digital safety,
the protection of children,
that's another obvious area.
All of these I think
are ripe for regulation.
And that's why we're seeing
more regulation in it.
I will say-- you're going
to get a kick out of this--
Microsoft is so good
at protecting security
that my company's
policies are telling me
that they're going to reboot
my computer in seven minutes.
So while I'm
listening to you, I am
trying to find a way to disable
that, which I may or may not
find in the next seven minutes.
So this will be one of the
more memorable security
updates in my life if
this, in fact, happens.
So let's see what we can cover.
I hope not.
I have not gotten to many
of the 200-plus questions.
I know.
But let me ask you
something about China.
So Microsoft has had a
direct presence in China
for a long time.
Your R&D initiatives
there are significant.
Can you tell us a bit
about your experience there
and how the current and
foreseeable political disputes
between US and China are
affecting you, if at all?
Yeah, no, they definitely are.
I think they're
affecting all of us.
I think it really has
a three-part impact.
First, it's having an impact
on supply chain stability.
And I think there are real
questions for the future as
to the degree to which
American tech companies will
be able to rely on the Chinese
supply chain for hardware.
Second, it's having an impact
on access to the Chinese market.
I think the Chinese
market has really
provided only limited access to
most American tech companies.
And that doesn't look
like it's going to change.
In fact, I think it may get
harder rather than easier.
And finally, I actually think
the single most important thing
for us to think about,
the thing that's
most important for Microsoft,
I would argue for MIT,
it's the intellectual
interaction.
China, as we all know, has
some of the world's greatest
engineers, software
developers, academics.
You know, software
is not created
in only a single country.
Especially with open source
techniques and the like,
it's created by people
working together.
And even if supply
chains change,
even if access to the
market is limited,
I think it's of profound
importance to the world
that people be able
to learn and study
and research and think together.
And I think preserving that,
amid these other challenges,
is really an important
priority for all of us.
What about a digital
iron curtain?
You talk in the
chapter about China
about the possibility of
a digital iron curtain.
We've also heard
former Google CEO Eric
Schmidt talk about splintering
the internet in two,
one Chinese led and
one non-Chinese led.
What would be the geopolitical
and economic impact
of this splintering?
And how do you see the creation
of this digital iron curtain?
Well, I think the world has
been splintering since 2010.
You know, the internet
in China is not the same
as the internet in
the United States.
But I think what we
now see more and more
is obviously a
degree of technology
competition between the
United States and China.
We see public policies
in both countries
focused on this competition.
I think increasingly,
American companies
have an advantage in
the United States,
Chinese companies have
an advantage China.
They compete with each other
in Europe and elsewhere.
We'll see.
It is increasingly a
bipolar technology world.
That's the phrase
we use in our book.
This will be, I think,
one of the defining
issues for this decade.
And a lot remains
unknown about how exactly
this is going to unfold.
We've talked about
a lot of challenges.
There is one big challenge
that is impacting everyone,
and that is climate change.
I personally believe
that our only way out
of this big challenge
is to figure out
how to cool the
planet by 1 degree
rather than figuring out
how to not warm up by more
than another 1 and 1/2 degrees.
And I was inspired when
earlier this year Microsoft
announced ambitious plans to
go carbon negative by 2030.
Not only that, but
also to turn back
the clock on all
the carbon Microsoft
has produced since 1975 by
counterbalancing that number
by 2050.
What do you see as
the biggest challenge
as you proceed with
this objective?
Well, we're going
to, first of all,
need a broad public
understanding and commitment
to the goal.
I think the goal needs to get
to be carbon zero, meaning
net zero by 2050,
meaning as a planet we're
removing every year as
much carbon as we emit.
Now to do that, then two
things become obvious.
We need to emit less carbon
and we need to remove more.
We need a number of techniques
to emit less carbon.
Digital technology
plays a powerful role
in our ability to measure
this, to create standards,
ultimately to reinforce
this through private action
and I think public
regulation in a way
that will drive emissions down.
But I think we also need a
massive investment, perhaps
the biggest R&D
challenge of the century,
to develop new techniques
to remove carbon
from the environment.
Things like direct air
capture are so clearly
in their infancy, they're
not yet cost effective.
And we're going to need
just huge breakthroughs
in that space over
the next three decades
if we are going to achieve this
fundamental goal of protecting
the planet the way we need to.
And we have a tragedy
of the commons here.
Many more companies have to step
up and follow Microsoft's lead
on this.
Because everyone
needs to pitch in,
otherwise we won't get there.
No, we do.
And I'm just going to say
now, in case you lose me
in one minute, thank you
for the 45 minutes rather
than the hour.
But let's hope that I
keep going with my update.
It's put off a few minutes.
So I'd like to switch
to some questions by--
Go for it.
This will be the
ultimate speed round.
OK.
So here's one.
How can workers proactively
expand on their skills
to adapt to the increasingly
digital AI-driven environment?
Well, I would say two things.
People who are not in the
computer and data science field
need to master more
digital skills.
But my plea to all of you,
because I think so many of you
probably are more in the
computer and data fields,
is don't neglect the other
aspects of the liberal arts.
Make sure that
you're in a position
to not only help drive
technology forward
but to think more broadly
about the use cases,
the fundamental
societal problems
you can help solve,
the ethical, almost
the philosophical issues, the
policy issues, the legal issues
that will also need to
be addressed in order
to advance technology in
a way that genuinely is
going to best serve the world.
I think only if
we're able to think
in a more multidisciplinary
framework than we have
in the past are we going to
be successful in ensuring
that technology serves the
public in the way it really
broadly needs to do.
This is definitely the spirit
of MIT's College of Computing.
OK, next question.
Does Microsoft
have plans to allow
people to work from home
permanently like Twitter
recently announced?
[COMPUTER TONES]
OK.
I wonder if we should
wait for a minute
to see if Brad can rejoin us.
Otherwise, I hope you've
enjoyed the conversation.
I certainly have learned
so much from Brad's wisdom.
I encourage all of
you to read his book.
It's really a tour de force
through many ethical challenges
that we as a community face
around the use of technology.
So let's see.
There's some questions
posted on Q&A.
And I am going to wait for just
a minute to see if anybody is--
oh, look, Brad is back.
Excellent.
We are so excited to
see you back, Brad.
[LAUGHTER]
I just hope I can stay.
OK.
Oh, I asked you a question
that made you run away.
There's a lot of benefits
from working at home,
but having your own home
computer managed by the company
may be one or not.
It definitely keeps
it more secure
but it adds this level
of unpredictability.
Let me just say, at
Microsoft we first
told people, hey, feel
comfortable working
from home through October,
until the beginning of November.
I think your real question is,
what does the future look like
when COVID-19 is a memory?
I think we'll have more
people working from home.
I still think we're
going to have offices.
You know, Satya Nadella,
our CEO, I think,
put it really well at a
conversation he had yesterday.
He said, let's not replace
one dogma with another.
The old dogma was everybody
needs to be in the office.
Let's not create
a new dogma that
says no one should ever
see each other in person,
we can all do things
through these screens.
I think that what
we're going to find
is more choices for more people.
We'll see the technology
continue to advance.
Certainly we're
working to accelerate
the pace of innovation for
our products, like Teams.
But I do think that
at the end of the day,
there is something
important about seeing
each other in person.
There is these
conversations that
happen before a meeting
begins, after a class ends.
I think there are still
important things that
happen when people sit down
and have lunch together.
So we should keep
all of that in mind.
I think we're going to live in
a world that has more of what
we call remote everything.
There will be more
remote digital services.
But I think our
ultimate goal should
be to bring out the
best of what that offers
and the best of what
we as human beings
get by being able to spend
time together in person.
So the next question is
how you envision the world
in the next 10 to 20 years.
You touched upon how we're
going to work post-COVID.
What about living and
playing and learning?
Well, in addition to working
at Microsoft every day,
I'm on the board of Netflix.
So I get to see things from
that perspective as well.
And let's face it,
this isn't just
something of the
last couple of months
where we're all relying
on remote entertainment,
but we've been seeing this
change over the course
of a number of years.
Yeah, clearly the use
of digital technology
is going to be one of the
defining trends of the 2020s,
as it really was for the 2010s.
But what I would say is that
while it has so much potential
to bring improvements
to people's lives,
we also do need to think
hard about the inequalities
that technology can create.
You know, income
inequality has become
one of the really
important issues
in the United States and
many other countries.
And digital technology,
to some degree,
has exacerbated that,
in part because we're
seeing tech companies do
so well, in all honesty.
Businesses that are not
grounded in technology
have had a harder time.
But I think it is
broader than that.
I think we live in a world
with internet inequality.
You see this very
sharply when you
see the tens of
millions of Americans
that don't have
access to broadband.
I think we live in a world
of educational inequality.
And digital skills and
the heightened need
for digital skills is
shining a spotlight on that.
I think we live in a world
where digital technology can
do so much but it can exacerbate
the inequalities, for example,
that people with disabilities
may confront, especially
if we don't do a great job
of designing technology
to meet their needs.
So I think that these
inequalities of the world
will be one of the important
issues of this decade.
They're all going to be
more pronounced because
of this extraordinary
recession, if not depression,
emerging from COVID-19.
And I think for all
of us who aspire
to have geeks as the heroes, as
you said, I think we need geeks
to be heroes and we need
teachers to be heroes
and we need public
officials to be heroes.
Because if we're not careful
these advances in technology
will make the inequalities
greater rather than smaller.
So let me try to get a few
more audience questions in.
What do you see as
the role of Microsoft
in the open source community?
Well, you know, one of the
more interesting few pages
in our book, I
would say, certainly
for those of us who are
involved in experiencing it,
and for Carol Ann and I
when we wrote about it,
is we acknowledge very
directly that Microsoft,
as they say in the book, was
on the wrong side of history
when open source really
exploded at the beginning
of this century.
And I can say that not
just about Microsoft,
I can say it about
me personally.
The good news is if
life is long enough
and you're successful
in other areas,
you can be on the
wrong side of history
and learn that you're there
and you need to change.
And that's what we did.
Today Microsoft is the
single largest contributor
to open source
projects in the world,
at least when it
comes to businesses.
And we're very proud of that.
When we look at GitHub,
we see GitHub as the home
for open source development.
And we have a
responsibility as a steward
to make it a great and
secure and productive home
for the world's open
source developers.
So we're much more now
in the open source camp
than outside it, even
if not every piece
of code that we write
is developed as part
of an open source project.
I think in some ways, one of
the other really interesting
questions for all of us is how
do we learn from open source
and apply that learning to what
we now refer to as open data.
We launched, just
a few weeks ago,
what we're calling an open
data campaign, a global effort
that we think, really
needs to be focused
on ensuring that more data
sets, perhaps especially data
sets that relate to great
societal issues, are opened up.
So we've created five
principles that we're
applying to ourselves and
the data that we have.
We're investing in more
work with nonprofits.
We're promoting public policy.
Ultimately, I think the
great need in the world
is to ensure that those
that have smaller data
sets, whether they be companies,
small businesses, universities,
or the like, have
the opportunity
to scale by federating their
data with data sets held
by other institutions.
But there is a
clear need to do so
with the kinds of
platform and tools
that a company like
Microsoft creates.
It is an imperative
to protect privacy.
We're very enthused about new
techniques like differential
privacy and where we see
that technology going.
There needs to be
the recognition
that people need to
be able to share data
without surrendering their
ownership or control of it.
There's a lot here
that is very broad.
And I think this is another area
that's really ripe for progress
at a place like MIT.
OK, so if you were
a student today,
what would be your major?
You know, I'd
majored, as I said,
I'm the liberal arts side of
liberal arts meets engineering
at Microsoft.
I like to quote
Steve Jobs, who said
that he worked every
day at the intersection
between engineering
and the liberal arts.
It is a way of reminding
us all that in fact we
need the kind of
multidisciplinary approach
that I was talking about before.
I majored in international
relations at Princeton.
I'd probably major again,
if I could, in history.
I have just found it
remarkably helpful for somebody
who does the work that I do to
be able to learn from the past.
You know, one of the
interesting things about history
is that ultimately there's sort
of the history of everything,
including the
history of science,
the history of technology.
I definitely would not be
the kind of student that
would study only one thing.
One of the great things you
realize later on in life
is that when you're
in a university,
it's an enormous opportunity
to study lots of other things.
And so that's what I would
encourage people to do.
Brad, there is a lot of
uncertainty in the world
right now and a lot of
reasons people feel anxious.
On the flip side, I'm just
curious what motivates you
and what makes your clock
tick and get up and open
the day with an exciting
outlook every morning?
Well, look, this is a hard time.
Let's just recognize
the obvious.
Even for those of us who
have the great good fortune
to have jobs, to not be among
the 36 million Americans who
have filed for
unemployment claims
in the last three months,
to be among the people who
are healthy, this is
a challenging time.
But I also think that because
of the challenging times
that we confront the truth
is the world has never
needed digital technology
to do as much as it
needs it to do right now.
And even when
COVID-19 is a memory--
it will become a memory--
you know, we're not going to be
talking about COVID-19 in 2030
as much as we'll be talking
about carbon, I suspect--
the world will need the kind
of technology we can create.
And when I say we, I don't
mean we at Microsoft,
I mean all of us who are
having this conversation.
I mean all of you who are
getting a degree at MIT
right now.
This is the future that
you're going to create.
And you have a
bigger opportunity,
I think, to have a more
important and more positive
impact in the world than perhaps
any generation that has ever
studied at MIT has had before.
Because digital technology is
just ubiquitous in the world.
And the opportunity to ensure
that it not only works well,
but it does good for
the world, oh, my
gosh, how can you not be
excited about getting up
in the morning.
That's sort of what I feel.
And yeah, I just am frankly so
happy I've had the opportunity
to work with great
scientists and engineers
on technology that matters.
And I really hope that
all of you will as well.
It's something that should
inspire all of us, I believe.
Well, this is fantastic
advice for our students.
Thank you for that.
If you go back 40
years, in hindsight,
what advice from a
global leader would
have been most useful
for you at that time?
You know, I've worked
with Bill Gates,
Steve Ballmer, Satya Nadella.
I've had the opportunity to meet
a lot of great world leaders
in my job.
The one thing that I find
truly successful people have
in common is enormous curiosity.
And I think it's something that
if you're at a place like MIT,
you probably have already.
But the advice I would
give is it's like a muscle.
Exercise it.
Use it.
Push yourself to read
more, listen more,
learn more in more fields.
Start with what is
at the core of what
is your major or focus
in graduate education,
but keep adding to that.
And what you'll find,
I think, is two things.
One is there are more dots
that you can connect than you
can ever would have imagined.
More things relate to each other
as you broaden the aperture.
But the second thing is
life is just more fun when
you ask people questions.
It's a lot more
interesting when you
get to learn from other people.
And develop that
sense of curiosity.
It's not only something that
will make you more successful,
I think it will make
your life more enjoyable.
And I benefited from a
lot of similar advice.
So I think I heard some of
that when I was a student.
But if I could go back in time,
I would write a little note
to myself and I'd probably
read it every morning.
Well, I'm inspired.
And unfortunately we are at
the top of the hour with you.
And we will have to save the
other questions for the future.
So I would like to
take this opportunity
to thank you for sharing your
wisdom and insights with us
and also give you
an open invitation
to come back for an
in-person visit to our campus
when we are open
for business again.
I look forward to
being there in person.
I always enjoy my visits.
It's great to connect
digitally, but it's even
more fun to be there in person.
So thank you.
Thank you, Brad, for
joining us today.
And thank you,
Daniela, for moderating
this truly fascinating and
really deeply informative
conversation, which I knew
it would be in advance.
But it's great to see
it actually realized.
And in fact, even the little
temporary gap in the middle,
at least for me, it gave me a
little bit of time to catch up,
because just this
constant sort of pacing
of questions and answers, I
needed a little processing
time.
So it just-- thank you so much.
Really fantastic.
Just one housekeeping thing--
While you were catching
up, I was panicking.
But it was, you know, it
was a good little interlude
for the audience--
Thank you.
--with 2020 hindsight.
Just remember, Microsoft,
we make software secure.
Yeah.
Well.
But this is the world.
If we're going to be
more secure, if security
isn't first, it never happens.
So it's actually a good lesson.
That's right.
We always put it off otherwise.
But just one housekeeping thing.
We'll be posting a
video of today's event
on both the CSAIL and
College of Computing websites
once we have the time to
get it closed captioned.
So thank you all.
Everybody, especially in these
times, take care and be well.
Thank you for joining us.
Thank you.